compact SUVs are the main money spinners
for the auto industry at the moment
almost all the marks in the Fox wagon
group have made SUVs for some years now
only one did not until now
Don is to survive but the time has come
says our test driver on droid Zimmerman
see at has debuted its first SUV it's
called the attacker and is based on vw's
MQB modular platform that means many
components have been tried and tested
and are already used in other models so
he's curious to see how the Spanish
cousin of the VW tiguan performs we're
testing the top of the line version
excellence it comes with climatronic
media system plus with 8-inch display a
range of driving modes and a rear view
camera equipped with the most powerful
engine it costs about 35 and a half
thousand euros in Germany 4,000 euros
less than the top-of-the-line VW tiguan
with the same engine
when's our test fog our test car has a
2-liter diesel engine it is a bit lame
under 2,000 rpm but beyond that it comes
into its own the 400 Newton meter talk
is certainly a match for the weight of
the vehicle see at says consumption is 5
liters 400 kilometers but most drivers
won't get that seven liters is more
realistic on a problem adeline the
attacker is one of several SUVs in the
VW Group with a four-wheel drive system
that distributes power to the front and
rear axles as needed
the attacker has the typical look of a
sea at full LED headlights are available
it's sharp exterior lines look lean and
dynamic
the trunk is spacious the rear seats are
oh me too you don't have to be a
subcompact person to feel at ease the
dashboard resembles that of the sea at
Leon the start button blinks like a
heartbeat Dez yet the Atika is based on
the Leon and it is of course very
similar to the VW Golf so it's no
surprise that the attacker drives like
you would expect it to personally he'd
like just a tad more sportiness like we
see in other sea at models that's
because of its higher center of gravity
but the Atika makes up for that with its
excellent suspension that evens out even
big bumps in the road on global 1m
heightened zell by victor dim see at is
offering various assist systems with the
MQB program traffic jam assist is one
option it helps handle stopping and
starting during congestion
an absolute own real highlight is the
emergency brake assistant which is
standard in all the versions of course
you hope you never need it but it is
good to know that it's there should your
concentration lapse for a moment he says
Alberta's good citizen that's bringing
hat photo and manage cancer off Maxim is
the latest version of the city emergency
brake function recognizes pedestrians as
well as cars it's a useful feature for
motoring in town the rearview mirrors
are large an optional extra is a blind
spot assistant it helps ensure you don't
overlook any vehicles as you turn or
change lanes the attacker is a true
sports utility vehicle an all-rounder
that fulfills its purpose wherever you
are
and cleaner it's a small step for the
auto industries as Andre but a huge step
for see at the attacker doesn't have any
weak spots it's spacious and it drives
well the entry-level model price of
20,000 euros in Germany is extremely
competitive for him the Atika looks
better than the to go for mr. attica de
shrew nana tiguan